a sea of yellow and green the colors of
Brazil's flag greeted president Jade
bolsonaro on his latest campaign stop
he reminded voters that he's recently
cut the price of petrol by half and
increased handouts to the needy but it's
something else that makes most
supporters worship him we don't want a
Brazil that goes like Argentina or other
countries we want the Brazil the
respective values of the family and
above all as the President says
Campinas is the second largest city of
Brazil's largest and most populous state
Sao Paulo and winning it on October 2nd
elections is vital to bolsonaro's
chances for a second term
[Music]
it is not difficult to convince you you
just need to look at other countries
that adopted communist ideology and show
how much Brazil was robbed between 2003
and 2015.
referring to the administration of his
formidable rival former left-wing
president luisi National
not a slogan in this election is Brazil
Above All Else and God above everyone
bolsonaro is anti-socialist
pro-conservative family values and
profoundly nationalistic a combination
that resonates with millions of
Brazilians like these
[Music]
nevertheless the latest polls show him
trailing behind Lula in two of Brazil's
three largest states and in a dead heat
in Rio de Janeiro which is supposed to
be bolsonata stronghold many here can't
believe it
the polls lie and the pollsters have
been built off
people here tell us they're fighting for
the soul of Brazil but should bolsonaro
lose to his ideological Nemesis in the
first round as Paul suggests he may the
president has hinted he won't take
defeat lying down
see a Newman Al Jazeera Campinas Brazil
[Applause]